E aí
[Música]
Olá eu sou uma apaixonada pela moda e
essa minha paixão já me levou até para
cadeia eu nasci em Recife e desde muito
pequeno já tinha um grande interesse
pelo assunto
e eu me lembro de observar as mulheres
da minha família eu lembro se para
costurar e crochetar roupa era um
processo que observava de longe já que
eu sempre escutei que moda e crochê eram
coisas de mulher há décadas mais tarde
eu entendi que aquilo não era verdade
eu trabalhei dentro do sistema de modo a
convencional por muitos anos
criando e lançando coleções autorais
sazonais mas com passado um tempo eu fui
tomando consciência
Oi Dulce pactos desse tipo de produção
dessa indústria tão poluente
e até aqui tem um pouco responsável por
seus impactos
eu fui aí eu comecei a procurar
respostas para a questão que me
incomodava como seria possível continuar
criando roupas e figurinos ou menos
Impacto Social e Ambiental
e nessa minha busca
burro novas saídas preço embate com a
moda eu comecei a me aproximar muito das
Artes manuais e acabei me reconectando
com crochê por intermédio de uma amiga
muito próxima
e a partir dessa minha reconexão com
crochê eu passei a ter autonomia já que
eu só precisava de uma agulha e um
novelo para criar peças incríveis
eu fui me desenvolvendo na técnica e
hoje além de continuar trabalhando com
moda e crochê eu ensino essas práticas
em um dos ambientes mais machistas da
nossa sociedade a cadeia
de acordo com o departamento
penitenciário Nacional O Brasil possui a
terceira maior população carcerária do
mundo
G1 prisões que estão sessenta por cento
acima da capacidade
hoje são cerca de 750 mil presos e 75
por cento desses presos não possuem
ensino fundamental completo A maior
causa do encarceramento é o tráfico de
drogas
seguido por roubo e furto esses três
crimes são responsáveis por quase
oitenta por cento das prisões no Brasil
e eu recebi um convite inusitado para
dar aulas para de tempo e eu aceitei
e quando eu cheguei na penitenciária e
me deparei com aquela Dura realidade eu
percebi a carência de atividades
produtivas e pudessem colaborar com
exceção daqueles indivíduos
foi pensando que eu poderia auxiliar
outras pessoas a desenvolverem sua
própria autonomia e eu criei o projeto.
Firme
desde 2015 uma vez por semana
acontecem as aulas desse projeto onde eu
levo capacitação técnica em crochê para
detentos da penitenciária Desembargador
Adriano Marrey em Guarulhos
e eu descobri que a técnica também
poderia ser usada como ferramenta para
educação
e já na primeira aula um aluno me
perguntou o professor tem alguma coisa
de crochê no Guinness Book
e eu não tinha conhecimento
se tinha algo de crochê no livro dos
recordes Mas eu percebi que existia na
telha aluno um desejo de ser grande
é uma vontade de fazer algo Notável
é aquela pergunta mexeu tanto comigo eu
precisava fazer o projeto do Ir Além
é a turma se aprimorou e passou a
desenvolver peças de crochê muito
elaborada essas peças começaram a vir a
roupa e essas roupas eram tão
surpreendentes
carregavam um tanto simbolismo que elas
precisavam ser mostradas além das grades
onde elas foram criadas Foi Assim Que
Nós criamos a nossa primeira coleção de
roupas e apresentamos um desfile no
maior evento de moda da América Latina
São Paulo Fashion Week
até aqui nós não entramos no livro dos
recordes mas com os trabalhos
desenvolvidos pelos alunos
nós já além de apresentarmos quatro
edições da São Paulo Fashion Week E
desde 2018 Nós também já participamos de
exposições na pinacoteca do estado na SP
arte e no Sesc Avenida Paulista
Nós já estamos meia tonelada de crochê e
se transformou em mobiliário de uma loja
em Nova York foi lançado um documentário
chamado o ponto filho um filme dirigido
por Laura Artigas e recentemente fizemos
uma coleção em parceria com uma grande
multimarca de luxo
e nós estamos usando o crochê para criar
coleções e contar a história de vida
desses homens e na sua maioria são
jovens que estão passando por essa
situação do Cássio e além de oferecer
uma atividade Educacional remição de
pena e a possibilidade de uma nova
perspectiva de vida para detentos
hoje o projeto também atua com egressos
do sistema prisional já que segundo
dados do ipea um em cada quatro
condenados reincidentes no fim
eu entendi que seria muito importante
oferecer uma oportunidade para quem
estava saindo do presídio e foi assim
que eu comecei a quebrar preconceitos e
a ter a colaboração de alunos artesão os
ingressos que hoje desenvolvem comigo
trabalhos em crochê para arte moda e
design
a ensinar crochê e dividir este
conhecimento com outras pessoas geram
grandes mudanças tanto na minha vida
como na vida dos alunos que estão no
projeto para minha alegria cada gresso
que me procura querendo continuar com
essas atividades é uma conquista é como
plantar uma semente lá na prisão e
sensibilizar aqueles ser humano nessa
tentativa de fazer essa semente germinar
e transformar vidas
os trabalhos geram benefícios sociais e
econômicos para todos os envolvidos
e eu acredito que é também um dever da
sociedade
contribuir para diminuição dos abismos
sociais
a encontrar soluções com pequenas ações
para que possamos reduzir a desigualdade
social e na minha opinião é um dos
maiores problemas do nosso país
é o que o projeto tem que ser e lidar
com todas essas questões e colocar o
crochê no meio disso para servir como
essa interface
Aonde a arte o manual ambiente para como
ferramenta de educação
com a simples ideia de pegar uma agulha
ensinar crochê nós estamos conseguindo
fazer uma mudança nesse sistema estamos
conseguindo tocar e mobilizar pessoas e
fazer a sociedade refletir sobre as
nossas cadeias
e no modelo atual o que elas se
encontram não vão recuperar ninguém
bom então a partir daí nós pretendemos
entender como que foi o caminho que
aquelas pessoas levaram até chegar no
Castro e o que nós vamos fazer com essas
pessoas quando elas Saírem de lá
se você já parou para pensar Como que
foi a infância dessas pessoas
e eu já escutei histórias muito tristes
e eu consigo entender a tragédia social
e humana que está por trás desta
população
é o ponto firme quebra um padrão a gente
leva design estética e afeto para dentro
da cadeia
Olá neste projeto sócio Educacional eu
tento olhar para essa ferida social que
ao encarceramento
Ah e assim nós vamos revelando a
humanidade que existe dentro de um
sistema criado para vigiar e punir o em
diante de todas essas questões eu decidi
não cruzar os braços
pois eu acredito que a moda e as artes
manuais podem contribuir sim para
recuperação EA reintegração dos
indivíduos
Você já parou para pensar
que dedicar um pequeno tempo da sua vida
para ajudar alguém
pode mudar e transformar não somente a
vida daquela pessoa mas a sua também
obrigado
[Aplausos]
E aí
[Música]